une petite signature pour une nouvelle
étape après quatre ans de vie commune
sigrid et pascal se sont pacsés cette
semaine à plaisir depuis le 1er novembre
les officiers d'état civil peuvent
enregistrer le pacte civil de solidarité
et d pour aller à versailles était
beaucoup trop long et c'est vrai qu'en
quand s'est passée au 1er novembre à la
mairie bas on a dit que on allait
attendre cette date là oui c'est une
démarche plus simple pour nous une
nouveauté qui semble intéresser les
plaisirs oies en seulement un mois 17
dossiers ont été déposés le délai actuel
dans cette commune une quinzaine de
jours
les agents ont été formés via la
préfecture
et c'est rentré aussi dans le plan de
formation continue que nous avons la
ville de plaisir
donc nous avons formé pour l'instant
trois agents mais à terme tous les
agents d'infiltration général seront
formés pour la signature du pacs un
dossier de pacs peut être pré remplie
sur le site internet service public.fr
il doit ensuite être déposé en mairie